I'm the guy that teaches you that if you
live with a plan on less than you make
and you stay out of debt invest your
money you will retire with dignity I'm
so old-school
and mathematically inclined that I can
prove that that happens over and over
again as a matter of fact we've been
interviewing millionaires here on the
air and been doing some millionaire
themed hours asking them how they became
millionaires and virtually every one of
them did not inherit wealth virtually
every one of them became millionaires by
living on less than they make saving and
investing very few of them ever made
over $200,000 in their lifetime
household income in a year the vast
majority of them were the tortoise not
the hare eighty eight percent of
American millionaires are
first-generation rich that means about
nine out of ten people that are
millionaires
started with nothing and became a
millionaire I am amazed that when for
instance today I tweeted at that
statistic eighty eight percent of
American millionaires are
first-generation rich that there is
always a group of people that want to
argue about that that don't believe that
and that that you know well they had a
head start
well they had white privilege well they
had this well they had that well their
momma knew somebody there whatever
there's always some kind of Lee and I
used to really get shocked by the huge
pushback against believing that you can
win in America today and you know what
it came to what I came to understand was
two things one is that some people have
their head stuck so far up their
politics that they can't think anymore
they don't know how to do critical
thought and they actually just believe
the party line so to speak
whether it's far right or far left in
this case it would be the the socialist
Bunch
they believe that opportunity
is gone from America today and that some
politician is the only way they're going
to get opportunity in and so that's one
of the reasons they want to push back
against that because they don't want to
believe that it's up to them the second
reason is is that I just am starting to
realize this and it makes me sad really
it's not a it's kind of pitiful that a
lot of people that want to argue that
opportunity has gone in America the core
reason that they want to argue that it
can't be done today is because if they
admit that it can be done today then
they also simultaneously would have to
admit that they haven't done it I would
have if I admit that you can go become a
millionaire today and I'm not one or I'm
not on a track to go get that then it
means I'm not doing what I need to do
and I'm not what you know it's
convicting to them when I say that
because it puts a mirror in front of
them and says you ought to go win in
there and they go well I'm not winning
and I feel bad about me for not winning
and nobody gave me a participation
trophy this week and so I've actually
got to get up and you mean I've got to
go do something different than I'm doing
now and they become convicted and then
they become very angry oh yes it is yes
it is just is you know the whole the
economy is rigged of course you know the
more liberal if you know somebody's are
real liberal if they say there are
systemic problems with the economy if
they use the word systemic because it
makes them sound sophisticated for being
a victim and you're not you're not you
can be a sophisticated victim or you can
be an unsophisticated victim in case
you're just a victim and what we
challenge you to do here is be the ear
oh we don't want you to be the victim we
would you be the hero we want you to
take life by the horns grab it and shake
it and make life behave is it going to
be perfect no are you going to run into
problems yes are you going to be
oppressed by fools and people that don't
agree with you that discriminate against
you yes count on it
women count on people putting you down
for being a woman
those of you that are from the south
count on people thinking you're ignorant
just because you have a southern accent
think about it our culture is so full of
stereotypes that you cannot avoid being
discriminated against some more than
others
I'm discriminated against because I'm a
Southern Christian white male think
about it like I got I'm as politically
incorrect as you can possibly be and I'm
bald on top of that you know I mean I
just about got all the bases covered and
so you know when I step into some of
these media situations it's like that
they look at me like I'm an absolute
[ __ ]
it takes in some cases me years to for
them to actually have at least a
grudging respect for who we are what we
do here everyone faces some kind of
hurdle from stereotypical morons who are
pushing back against you so just count
on that that's part of the journey baby
doll it's not you know suck it up
buttercup you got to do it and the
government's not going to fix it there
is not anybody running on the right
that's going to make your life good
there's not anybody running on the Left
that's going to make your life good 88%
of Americans millionaires are still
first generation rich and only 1% of
them are actors athletes and rock stars
most of them are small business owners
they're in sales something like that I
just poke they just decide to live
different than normal people who spend
everything they make and act like
they're in Congress they made a decision
to live differently now you can choose a
victim mentality due to your liberal
politics due to your shame about your
position you can choose a victim
mentality but I can 100% guarantee that
you will not win choosing that mentality
I want you to choose the hero
I want you to choose then in spite of
the obstacles in spite of the people
that put you down in spite of the people
that tell you it can't be done in spite
of your sixth grade teacher or your mean
mother-in-law in spite of whoever it is
go do it anyway go win anyway and don't
let a Republican or a Democrat or a
conservative or liberal or someone of
faith or someone without faith steal
your dreams you see hope is an
interesting thing no one can take it
from you the only way hope leaves you as
you surrender it don't surrender your
hope don't quit believing that it can be
done in spite of how freakin hard it is
it's hard but it's the only option
so it's worth it live like no one else
so that later you can live and give like
no one else
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you are
not a victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim
Oh